good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Gershon today we go behind
the scenes of the oldest university
based Art Museum in the United States
Yale University art gallery founded in
1832 our guide is gallery director
Jacque Reynolds who's led the museum
from 1998 onward a period of
transformative growth both of the
galleries physical space and of the
exceptional collection of art inside
as always we'll take some of your
questions please submit them to Twitter
via at Yale or by email to social media
at yale.edu jock thanks for being with
us my pleasure great to be here it's
been an amazing year for Yale University
art gallery you completed a I believe it
was a decade-long renovation and
expansion you opened that a year ago
tomorrow that's correct
tell us a little bit about how this
enormous renovation and expansion
changed the art viewing experience yeah
well first of all what's really
important to know is the renovations and
expansion of the art gallery took place
within President Levin's entire
redistricting of the arts area the
master plan for all of the arts at Yale
so we were just one element and what
happened but what the switching around
the buildings and the construction of
new buildings and renovations made
possible was for the art gallery to
basically re re inhabit and restore all
three of the historic buildings on
Chapel Street that is inhabited with its
collections and faculty from 1960 excuse
me 1866 when the art gallery moved into
the first school of art building in
America Street Hall
- it's 1928 old arielle art gallery
designed by adjutants Ward Howe in its
1953 Lois Cobb building designed by the
great architects on who also did the
British Art Center 25 years later
so you've connected three buildings that
were near each other but you you
couldn't otherwise accidents they were
directly adjacent to each other so the
architecture we did with any added
Associates literally allowed us to to
move people directly from one building
to the next to the next so I it really
feels to me like a great three-course
meal
architecture if you will you it's a much
enlarged gallery but when you walk into
each building each one and it is a great
piece of architecture of its time and
the contents what we put on display
there have been thoughtfully arranged to
be visually consonant and poetic with
those three structures and we've added
some really wonderful architecture to
the top of the building that's
contemporary and and due to you know
also the issues of needing to make these
buildings readily accessible full
handicapped access to all three of them
now what this is amazing about this is
you take a guess if you know those dates
how many years of deferred maintenance
were fixed in this project it totals two
to two hundred and eighty years none of
those buildings have been renovated
since they were first built so this was
a major campaign to bring the buildings
back to the full stature and beauty of
what they were originally in a sense
they were the three great artworks
architectural II that contained the
galleries collections over time and now
display them and their fullest beauty
once again there are very different
buildings architecture Lee speaking and
yet when you proceed from say the Kahn
building into is it Street halls at the
next one well no it's not the old DLR
gallery the sworn out building right the
name of the architects yeah it doesn't
it doesn't it isn't jarring at all when
you go from this sort of modernist Kahn
building yeah into the much older
building yeah well I think one thing if
you if you go to something like the met
or the loo of some of these great
buildings which have a more singular
sense of architecture you tend to get a
little bit exhausted by it after a while
which is the distinct differences
between these three buildings and a
funny way refresh you when you go from
one or the other and of course all of
our curators and people we worked with
together thought about which collections
are most appropriate to put in the comm
building or the sort out building or
Street Hall and I think that's that it's
not just the renovation of the buildings
but the installations my colleagues have
created they've also made it the
beautiful experience it is one of the
interesting things about the renovation
is that you seem to have created a lot
of new views and vistas from both inside
the museum and on top of it
Yale and of downtown new hata have you
curious to hear a little bit about the
thinking behind that I was obviously
delivering yeah that was very purposeful
actually I'm glad you asked that
question because that's the other thing
if you're in a museum you sometime
really want and need different kinds of
releases and reliefs from the intense
experience of looking at art and what
could be more beautiful and to look out
across this great campus and city from
various perspectives and a sense to
refresh your eye and relieve your visual
palette for a moment and also frankly to
look at the other architecture that
exists on this beautiful campus and city
and so we made a lot of decisions and
and having the time to do it with a
process that was really a two-stage
process there were two points in which
we did the actual renovation over two
three your periods we got to think a lot
about which windows do you want to keep
open which ones might you want to close
for an exhibition wall so a lot of
thinking and reflection went into that
and I have to say the architects were
great to work with but our staff was
really wonderful in helping us arrive at
the aesthetic decisions to have certain
views and in some cases closed off
others now it seems to me that most most
Art Museum's and most first-rate art
museums are freestanding in a way but
Yale art gallery is nestled within a
major university I wonder if you would
talk a little bit about how that makes
the gallery how it sort of distinguishes
the gallery from other great museums
yeah well one thing that's a lot of
people don't normally think about it
heels actually the only Ivy League
school that has a professional school of
visual art a School of Music a school of
drama and architecture others have
architecture but it's the one Ivy League
institution in which from the very
beginning what John Trumbull came as an
artist to build and design and install
his own work in the art gallery in 1832
a living artist was accepted as a
central member of the college and later
university community so Yale is a place
where you know my training as an artist
where you feel completely comfortable is
the true member of the academic
community here and our professional
schools not only trained some of the
great artists in the in the world but we
also teach her undergraduate courses
from the faculties of those professional
schools and it was only really later in
1940 believe it or not that Yale added
the the full discipline of art history
in an art history department so Yale has
been uniquely artist centric and had the
first school of art and also the first
school
in America so that there's been a it's
you know it's in the water and in the
DNA of this place very deeply at this
point it also serves an important role
cultural role in the city of New Haven
yeah I was in there earlier today and
there are schoolchildren traipsing
around everywhere and really being
engaged by I don't know if they were
docents from the gallery itself or their
teachers from yeah well we've you know
one of the things we've really done in
the last 15 years and we started it in a
big way in the year 2000 as we really
redefined our mission to be not only a
museum with a great collection but to
put our collecting you know part of the
mission an equal balance with our
educational mission we are first and
foremost a teaching Museum with a great
collection and what we've done in the
intervening years is to not only create
many more facilities for sharing the
collection there now eight object
classrooms and the and a whole Learning
Center and there's a whole teaching
gallery in the museum but even more
importantly we've given more
undergraduate and graduate students
central roles and guiding students other
students and colleagues in the public
through the collections and we now have
an endowed graduate student teacher
program that teaches directly from the
collection now these people are guided
and trained by some of our great art
historians and curators and volunteers
on our board but more and more we
entrust students to take a strong role
in what we do there's currently a
student curated exhibition on the fourth
floor of the con villain we've done six
of those in recent years there are three
more in production so this is a place
where students get not only exposure to
great works of art but they really learn
if they want to they can engage themself
in any aspect of the museum practice and
learn a lot about through doing while
we're in our midst and yet the
collection is in fact and has been
growing enormously in the last 15 years
or so know if you would discuss a little
bit the priorities that have driven
acquisitions at the gallery well one of
the things that's been most interesting
and the era when president xi was
president it's it's clear to everyone to
the yale became a much more global
university we now have students from all
over the world studying here one of the
exciting things that happen is
actually added four more departments to
the art gallery during that time and two
of them were especially important and we
are added to a whole new Department of
African art which covers a whole
continent that was really only
represented with a small group of works
but not a department and we've added a
major department of indo-pacific art
which is again takes on all the sea
cultures in the South Pacific all the
way down from you know basically the
Barbossa used to be off China all the
way down to India and and we've added a
whole Department of coins and medals and
we've broken our department of early
European art and modern art into two
major departments because the
collections are so strong so if you walk
into the art gallery now as a student
from almost anywhere in the world to
some degree you can see your own
identity or your own culture in some way
and feel that you know there's something
that the necessity of you or your
heritage there to be seen and I think
that's an important thing as well as it
that you can learn from you know the
cultures and expressions of other people
across time and and that's been very
exciting to be able to provide that and
to also along with that provide that
endowed positions and the funding that
made those new departments and the
naming of galleries possible so that
that coincided also with what I call a
great leaven period of sort of Yale's
globalization the collection is enormous
at this point it's something like 200
thousand total objects many fewer on
display of course but can you name maybe
one or two of the many many acquisitions
in the last you know 15 years or so that
that you're especially proud of well you
know what's interesting is you could you
could name a single work or two but in
fact what's been amazing is in the case
of some of the things I was just talking
about Charles Benenson gave his entire
African art collection to Yale almost
600 works and 192 major works of modern
and contemporary art Richard Brown Baker
gave his entire collection I mean it
wasn't it's not as though I couldn't
also it's not individual worse now gross
yeah and it's just in in some cases
people have brought us whole major
bodies of artwork that we didn't have
before so that's been almost stupefying
the generosity
of what some donors have added to the
collection and some of them but some of
these collections have come from people
who are not Yale alumni but are
interested in a teaching Museum that
also serves the community of New Haven I
wanted to jump back a bit to your
question when you were asking about you
know the you know what we see school
children you see a lot of people from
the city and the gallery now that you're
absolutely right to perceive that when
Street Hall was given to Yale College
and was constructed believe it or not
during the American Civil War between
1864 and 66 it was given by the streets
a couple from New Haven who had seen the
great Ecole des beaux-arts in Paris and
they came back and said New Haven needs
something like this and Yale does and
they gave it to Yale but the proviso
that its front door opened on to Chapel
Street and be available to the city and
the other side door open to the old you
know campus so a lot of people don't
know this but the the first women to get
degrees at Yale were happening back in
the in the latter part of the the 19th
century almost you know almost a hundred
years before Yale College went co-ed and
educational programs for people from
city of New Haven to come in and study
and and and visitors from the city to be
involved with the gallery just happened
very very early on and there's there's
no admission no the galleries it's
always free and and Paul melon's who was
a member of the gallery's board when he
gave the British art center across the
street entirely paid for that and the
last major gift of mr. melons life which
was 95 million dollars came with a
stipulation that Yale never charge
admission to the British Arts Centre so
between these two teaching museums you
frankly have two of the greatest
collections in the world of their kind
and no one has to pay a single dollar to
walk in the front door which means that
you can often just come in and maybe
look at your favorite painting for five
or ten minutes to not feel you have to
try to get your $25 ticket worth and it
allows frankly individuals and families
from all walks of life to come and feel
that it's it's their institution and we
make a real point of wanting people now
although Yale is clearly perceived as a
you know an elite Ivy League institution
that this is an institution that which
we welcome all the public and anyone who
wants to come our way and you can't say
that enough
so with a large collection with 200,000
items you can only have I imagine a few
thousand on display at any given time
yeah how do you and your curators go
about deciding when it's time to add
something new from the existing
collection and put it on public display
yeah one of the questions you asked
yourself
yeah well that's it's a great question
because one of the first conversations I
had with president what 11 when he hired
me as he said he said Chuck don't just
ask me for a bunch more gallery space he
said do something to make these
collections more readily accessible and
usable he said I know how large they are
I know they're going to grow but you
know we've got to find a way to share
this work more fully and he was
absolutely right so that's been done in
a number of way first of all to even
know what you want to show and to let
people know what's there we had to
photograph and document the collection
you know libraries were way ahead of
museums and putting their collections
online but you know the art gallery 15
years ago had about 1,500 of its
artworks photographed we now have a
hundred and thirty-five thousand of the
two hundred thousand done and a lot of
the ones still to do or decorative art
objects or coins and metals so you can
go on the internet or a Yale student or
a kid in high school you can go on and
see an awful lot of what we have online
and know what our teacher can decide
what they might want to see and then the
other key thing was to create these
object classrooms in places that if
something wasn't physically on view in
the gallery you could ask for it and
bring it into an object classroom for a
class session or professors could ask
some things that weren't in the
collection galleries to go to the new
teaching gallery atop the sort out
building but then the other key thing
that people often don't think about is
you've got to have staff to do this so
we had to jump tremendously the number
of registrar's art handlers people to
get the stuff out and to carefully
handle it and bring it into the
galleries whether you're gonna install
it in the galleries or whether you're
gonna bring it to a classroom our
personnel growth went from sixty sixty
eight full-time people to 147 now in the
time I've been here and a lot of that
has to do with making the collections
accessible by documenting them and then
bringing people in in direct contact
with original works of art which is our
greatest desire we're happy that someone
in in Moscow today can watch this
program or go on the internet and see
what we have but we most be happy if
someone could eventually get here to
see the works if they can but let me
follow up on digitization a little bit
it's something that's happening here
it's happening I imagine it at most
museums how is it changing the way
museums think about their mission well I
think you know when you have so many
things that people give you that they've
lived with and treasured and you just
say you own them and you don't make use
of them you're really not doing them any
service for their generosity and you're
not honoring the art itself I mean it
means nothing to say your stuffs in a
collection and this at some point it
becomes visible in some way so you know
making it visible through digital means
or in books you know the traditional
ways that's been done is important but
we really maintain that it's that direct
contact with the original work of art
that gives you that special feeling and
that's something that really happens
when you're just right there in front of
it for example if you look at most
screens or most books and then go see a
painting in a gallery you're always
early struggle how the scale that looks
completely different often you know the
paintings are all sides similarly in a
book and you go to a gallery and you
find one of them you know 14 inches by
16 inches the other is 8 feet tall by
you know 4 feet wide so and then you
don't see the texture of the painting
and the book or the way the impasto the
paintings put on so we really believe
that the work of art carries its own
complex information and then that's the
other reason we want to make the
original available as much as possible
but in order to make that possible you
want people to know what you have even
as you change what's actually on display
at any given time within the physical
museum there must be certain pieces
because of the extraordinary wonder they
inspire in people because of their sheer
celebrity yeah are always on display and
almost never come down except perhaps
for restoration or yeah or something can
you talk about some of those that are
well you're absolutely right well look
the great founding collection that John
Trumbull you know brought when he
designed the Trumbull gallery and
installed his own personal collection it
was basically his great portrait of
Washington it was the great
Revolutionary War battles and it was the
defining the two paintings that
bracketed them that Thomas Jefferson
urged him to
which was the signing of the Declaration
of Independence and Washington giving up
his commission Jefferson said great do
the battle history paintings the way
they do in England and France but what
was unique about America's this is what
we did it for and Washington could have
been King George the fourth he decided
to give up his commission you have to
paint those as the bracket to the wars
and what a wonderful you know sort of
decision and encouragement that was
remember Trumbull he's no father was the
colonial governor of Connecticut the
first one to break with the British and
so you know when he came back as a young
man
after the war when people like Benjamin
West and and Hilbert's Stewart and and
Copley were making a lot of money in
late careers in London he was the young
person who came back and to some degree
allows us to see what are the founding
of our country looked like who those
principal people were and that was an
amazing thing that had happened and it's
over the Yale art gallery opened in 1832
that's 40 years before the mat opened
and the the the Hartford wats where
that's named woman died in 1842 the
first major civic museum so Connecticut
occupies actually a very formative
period in the advent of art in America
so the Trumbull paintings are always on
view the great van Gogh night cafe many
of our great homers and Aikens paintings
or our great Roscoe's and pollux I'm
used to I mean I can you can tick
through the gallery there are certain
things that have such dynamic presence
you just you look at them and this is
the power of a great work hard you said
don't you dare take me off the wall or
you know some work really fights to stay
in place but you were asking you know
about making things successful what we
do now is to rotate the collections much
more vigorously and so you know at least
three times a year if often more and
many deploys a permanent collection
permanent collections are changing all
the time and because we have over 50,000
works on paper in that building that can
be accessed in our study rooms works on
paper often can only be up for a few
months and then they're taken off you
but we want people to know that
particularly in our prints drawings of
photography collections that there are
things that you can see in the galleries
sometimes briefly but they're right
upstairs and you can book them for an
exhibition or private or individual
research so making the collection
readily accessible happen
in many ways Jack I'm going to take a
question from a viewer Mike H writes by
email to ask which artist currently not
represented in the museum do you think
would complement or sort of flesh out
the the collection is there somebody
you're really hungry for well you know
tittering you say that we just made an
acquisition that with it's gonna go on
view and in march by david park
it's a bits painting called the model
and we happen to own some great
paintings by Richard Diebenkorn and
Elmer Bischoff who were two of the great
San Francisco Bay Area artists where I
grew up out in California but their
great teacher and mentor was David Park
and it just so happens that there was a
wonderful woman here in Connecticut who
at one point bought his I think one of
he is truly greatest if not his greatest
painting and it had finally emerged from
that estate and we've purchased it and
starting toward the end of this coming
March you're gonna see a great display
of some of our American art from that
wonderful period of the 50s and 60s and
in the Bay Area so you know all the time
we're looking for sometimes key works
that we can acquire and some of these
come up as opportunities out of nowhere
and some of them we research and keep
hunting until we find something that we
really feel fills a gap and adds
strength either strength on strength or
where it fills the lacunae and the
collection in a powerful way that's one
of the great things that our all our
curators do and and and that's where
knowledge matters when I take another
question this one also by email from
Duncan G who asks how are the
collaborations with other colleges such
as Bowden and Williams working out and
do you think you'll expand that to other
museums yeah oh thank you for asking
about that one of the other ways we've
decided to make the collections truly
and more readily accessible and actually
they'll learn something from doing it
ourselves was about six years ago we got
a major grant from the Andrew Mellon
Foundation and we invited six New
England College museums that are
outstanding but have much smaller
collections than ours to come to us for
their with their curators and faculty
and say what would you like to borrow we
were in the midst of renovations we said
you know no holds barred what you know
just tell us what would you like to
borrow in order to teach a course or
courses you couldn't otherwise teach if
you borrowed things from
and we did that with Bowdoin College we
did it with Dartmouth we did it with
Mount Holyoke we did with Williams
College we did it with Smith and we did
it with Overland and what came out of
that was so fascinating in terms of the
installations and the shows our
colleagues at other institutions did
that were interesting to us and clearly
memorable for them and allowed them to
teach more fully in ways they had not
been able to do without such single
source loans but we learned something
about our collections anytime someone
shows your work in a different
configuration researches that teaches
with it differently you learn more
that's been so successful that we've
continued that program or we recently
received a multi-million dollar
endowment to support that perpetually so
you're going to see a lot more and we've
actually already done some other
collaborations with American
universities and colleges but that's
going to continue on as a constant of
our museum going forward so digitization
to sort of link these two topics a
little bit doesn't seem in any way a
disincentive for museums to to actually
share the physical works of Arts
themselves not at all I thought the the
beauty of digitization and we have you
know that's great powerful databases
that when you're thinking about an
exhibition you want to do you can just
go under the database and say well you
know what are we owned by Winslow Homer
and it'll throw up all these paintings
and prints and drawings and watercolours
and you can say well if I want to you
know select from this you know you don't
have to go physically immediately look
at every drawer every painting rack to
see it but you can at least from these
thumbnail reproductions or blow them up
full on your screen you can do you can
sort of make preliminary checklist for
what you put in an exhibition or a book
or a course that's very valuable there's
nothing in and what could be better in a
sense it's a deep visual reference
library in addition to the information
that comes with the database so that you
know knowing what you have in order to
it's like having you knowing all the
ingredients you have available if you're
a great cook I mean you don't want to
just think he got five or six things to
cook with you know you want the what's
in the whole pantry but also people
people who were seeing these works of
Arts through digital means initially
aren't satisfied necessarily that
doesn't see their desire to sort of
interact with the art yeah
well one of the things I noticed just
because I'm so visually attuned to
issues of color and scale and everything
is you know everyone's device often has
a different color balance so sometimes
what you think is even the color of an
image once you actually come to see it
and in the flesh depending on how you
viewed it wherever you are is very
different and there you know as I
mentioned there all these other aspects
of you know a three-dimensional work you
can't walk around it on that on unless
you get three or four views of it in a
digital database so they're depending on
the artwork it's always best if you can
get the chance to look at the original
but having the basic reference you know
of the work itself is important because
without it you know how do you think of
what you're gonna draw on and make
accessible and then you tend to I think
rely too much on just the great
chestnuts and the collections become a
little more static and and sometimes
just even moving great worked into
different configurations and
juxtapositions with each other changes
your sense of how to experience them you
have been running art galleries and
museums for decades now San Francisco
Washington Massachusetts here in New
Haven have these skills required to run
a an art museum changed in any
appreciable way in the time that you've
been doing it what is I guess what I'm
trying to get at is this is the 21st
century art museum leader significantly
different in some essential way from
somebody doing in 1950s yeah I think
people expect much more of museums now
than they did in their beginning museums
when they were founded did have a
smaller viewership smaller sense of you
know who was who was involved in working
in them who was funding them you know
was a the scale of it has changed
dramatically I would say what still is
essential is to be a good museum
director you really have to understand
know and care about be passionate about
art and and in my case there are certain
areas in which I'm an expert in other
areas where my colleagues know so much
more than I do but they at least
appreciate my eye and my visual judgment
then you know at least in my case
everything since you know to learn about
administer
and Finance and legal and construction
and architectures some of that I learned
as an artist having to renovate
buildings for my own lofts and studios
as he is a young artist some of it I
learned when I was helping other artists
of my age great alternative art spaces
and sort of a seat of a pants
education where we all had to do this to
help each other support our work when we
were rolling out of graduate schools in
the late 60s and 70s and trying to
figure out how to be artists in America
which isn't an easy thing to do and then
running these bigger institutions the
complexity of budgets and the cost of
producing shows and the escalation of
values of artwork and the the huge
amounts of insurance and courier flights
and everything involved everything's
gotten more complicated and I'll give
you a good example this Francis Bacon
painting that just triptych sold for a
hundred and forty million dollars a
couple weeks ago what do you think it's
gonna do to some of these future big
blockbuster shows when paintings get
escalated into values of that scope one
well the cost of then insuring those
paintings and getting them to museums
where they're going to charge these
prices for tickets how much higher can
these ticket prices go how much can
people afford to do some of this these
there are a lot of pressures in the art
world now that are on a lot of museums
and I have to say being in a university
of college art museum where what we do
is so integral to the educational music
mission and where our collections are so
strong we can draw on our collections
you know which are just there for us in
a single source in a way that very few
institutions can we're in a wonderful
position to to be self-reliant and to
share as I mentioned our collections
generously with others and to do it
without trying to monetize our
collections we are not trying to
monetize our collections and we've just
gone to a free membership program as
well it's a little bit more like public
radio where you know you take advantage
of a great resource and if you want to
contribute back with gifts of your time
or art or money you can do so when we're
finding a wonderful response that's
historically been there like that but it
seems to be increasing let me ask you
about another issue in in art outside of
Yale the Detroit Institute of Art is in
a is in a tough spot right now because
it's a publicly owned collection and
this
Detroit is in bankruptcy and there's
been some talk about by the bankruptcy
administrator of perhaps selling off
some of that collection in order to help
pay off the city's debt so do you what
is your sense of how that's playing out
and likely to plan yeah well it's a very
complicated situation gramby love
director is a good friend of mine
Richard Manoogian who named our American
art galleries is the past chairman of
the board of that institution so you're
right it's a city owned and it's been
heavily subsidised by the city and it's
had periods of time and economic turmoil
well it's been able to be open or closed
lesser days the you know this isn't the
first time they've had some trouble but
when it comes to perhaps selling some
works in the collection I don't think
it's that well understood that a fair
number of the greatest works you know
probably the quite a bit of the majority
of them were given by private and to
people and not bought by public money so
the old ultimate value of that
collection is staggering if it were to
go on the market but the things bought
with actual city based funding is
probably not as as big as possible and I
found it incredibly heartening that the
regional towns the suburban towns were
willing to vote a tax on themselves to
preserve and help fortify the budget of
the Detroit are destitute
so that support is quite unique in a
time when most people are resisting
taxes so that and it's a beautiful
museum I mean I just love going there
and it was the first major museum in
America to buy a lot of the great art
when the Fords and you know the the
great wealth of America was centered in
Detroit and then the in the 20s in
particular in early 30s so I think
frankly they're gonna work that out in
some way whether it's some kind of
private buyout of some of these things
that contributes some money to the city
to distribute but because with a tragedy
of Detroit is that these people who work
for the city and and have these
legitimate pension obligations that
should come their way should not be left
in their old age to not have what was
rightfully theirs and so I I think
they're still going to be some positive
way that works out because if you
denigrate that collection in significant
ways it's going to be very hard to build
confidence to enhance it again when the
city gets back on its feet and and they
think this is a problem in museums
people start whether it's for duress or
whether you want to sell a great
painting in order just let's create a
new acquisition fund you know how our
people are going to feel when you take
some of your greatest treasures and sell
them when they thought they were going
to reside there in perpetuity I frankly
would expect to be dumped out the front
door if I proposed to sort of sell so
far our great pain is just to maximize
new acquisition funds in fact I think
you were asking about things directors
need to do is you know big part of what
I and others need to do is to find
people who care enough about different
aspects of the museum and are willing to
fund it
and in our case we've spent most of our
time wanting to build our endowment so
that the whenever possible with the
great management of David Swensen it you
know we've put money into endowment
endowment endowment because if you try
to live only off your salary you're not
going to run an art museum so you know
it's and that I learned that running
these alternative art spaces where every
year I had to turn right around and
raise the whole budget again so I'm a
kind of an endowment freak let me take
another question from a viewer this is
from Omar this is a sort of a Yale
centric question actually - can you talk
a little bit about the conservation
efforts going on at Yale's West Campus
which is a relatively new part of the
university and the interaction to the
extent there is one with with the
gallery
yeah well it's very exciting the X in
the next year - you're gonna start to
hear much more about Gail's West Campus
there's a very large building out there
that was it was originally part of the
miles laboratories before Bayer bought
it out it's a over 425 thousand square
foot building to put it this a little
bit in a visual perspective it's being
roof re-roofed right now and the rooftop
is 10 acres so put that in your mind for
scale this building has now been given
over to the major collecting
institutions of Yale the Peabody Museum
the British Art Center yells musical
musical instrument collection the Yale
art gallery and we're in the process
we've already established wonderful
science conservation research labs there
we're building out a major conservation
center there we've established a new
digital center there and we just last
week the Provost have approved a major
open study storage collection area that
the gallery is going to be developing
over the next two years and so there's
gonna be much more on display this gets
again to the idea of having the
collection readily accessible and
treating it and having students and
people engage it that's all going to be
happening out there in addition to what
we do downtown and again will expand
Yale's engagement with art in a very
deep way and do something else the
president Levin wanted which was to have
a situation where you would you would
have expertise from the arts humanities
and Sciences doing research and work
together on West Campus so you know I'm
frankly wishing I were 10 or 15 years
younger right now let me ask you about
yourself a little bit you as you
mentioned earlier in the show you you
are an artist do you have I can't
imagine that you have a whole lot of
time to make art these days but maybe
you do and I have to believe you have
some some things in mind yeah you know
what's what's going on for you well
actually it's sitting you asked that
question because my wife and I have
collaborated as artists for you know
since we met in the mid-70s and we've
just been asked actually if we'd
consider doing a commission for the
centennial of the panamanian the Panama
exposition at San Diego for the
Contemporary Art Museum out there it was
run by someone who's been after us to do
something for years and now we're trying
to figure out whether there'd be any way
we could produce a new work for this you
know takes a little bit of time off to
do it yeah I think that being able to
still make art you know before I you
know go to the great beyond it's still
something I want to get back to I've
signed up for my fourth five-year term
here and if you if you were to ask me
well what would you speculate doing
beyond five years it might be to stay
here in New Haven and just maybe teach a
course a year and and make art and maybe
be one of the artists residents out in
West Campus and and stay engaged because
I love being around the students and the
faculty in this community and we found
it a wonderful place to live and be the
the the renovation the expansion was a
massive project costly took many years
there I imagine there must be some
temptation to take a deep breath and
just rest for a minute but but I know
that you're ambitious and Yale is
ambitious
other other other big projects that
you're eager for the gallery to take on
what yeah of any kind well there are the
West Campus you just ditched on the the
other project I really hope to get done
before I leave his directors to unify
some of the staff offices that are in
the immediate downtown one thing I
didn't mention is when we cleared out
those three buildings that are now that
Yale art gallery proper we call it sort
of the mothership on Chapel Street we
took an awful lot of our offices out of
those buildings with the idea to
maximize more of these object classrooms
and galleries so we're actually staffed
in four different buildings in the
immediate area downtown and we've been
offered a building by Yale to move into
on Crown Street but it's another one
that requires about just under 20,000
square feet but it's going to require
about a fifteen million dollar
renovation so you know there's more
money to raise my first obligation
frankly is director right now working
that the university and staff is to get
its fully back to the kind of secure
financial position we were in before the
art galleries and Yale's endowment took
a strong hit in the in the recession of
2008 because you know so many people
suffered a big you know downturn and the
value their endowments or their
contributions whatever we were frankly
deeply fortunate that we haven't had to
layoff a single person we were able to
raise the money from our donors to
finish the renovation even in the teeth
of the recession but Yale still has an
overall small structural deficit we're
all trying to eliminate and build our
endowment back to the point that you
know my greatest hope was to leave my
successor in a very strong and firm
financial position but still hungry to
do wanna raise money for new projects
yeah we're gonna wrap this up in just a
minute but I have to ask about a
tombstone that I noticed when I went
through the gallery most recently of
John Trumbull is it true that he at one
time was buried beneath the gallery
remind viewers who he is
well John Colonel Colonel John Trumbull
the the founding artist who created the
Yale art gallery back in 1832 was in
fact actually buried along with his wife
under the original John the Trumbull
gallery on
tl campus that building was torn down in
1901 at Yale's Bicentennial and his
remains were placed under Street Hall
later transferred which is now one of
the yeah but it yeah but then they were
later transferred underneath to the
Swart a building for a while when the
one art history it took over Street Hall
for a while the the the the original
document said his he needed to always be
near his Washington paintings underneath
them and Yale observed that very
strictly and said when we renovated
Street Hall which was the the building
of the first school of art we re buried
he and his wife are under there right
under his paintings down under the
bottom of street hall and and I always
tell people we have the longest artisan
residence in America Drakh Reynolds
director of the Yale University art
gallery thank you for spending some time
with us today thanks to all of you for
watching and please do join us again
next time I pleasure